merci beaucoup d'être notre invité
politique ce matin d'éviter des Yvelines
président du groupe Renaissance à
l'Assemblée nationale on va commencer
par le plan de sobriété c'est à la une
de la plupart de nos quotidiens
régionaux ce matin plein de sobriété
présenté hier par le gouvernement 15
mesures qui incitent les Français à
adopter des gestes pour réduire leur
consommation mais qui encourage aussi le
télétravail et qui donne aussi des
recommandations pour les entreprises les
administrations il y a pas d'obligation
il y a que des incitations vous pensez
vraiment qu'avec uniquement des
incitations on peut atteindre l'objectif
qui est le vôtre de réduire la
consommation d'énergie de 10% d'ici 2
ans il y a quand même les obligations
pour l'État c'est à dire on part du
principe que c'est d'abord l'état qui
doit être exemplaire avant de demander
évidemment un certain nombre de mesures
pour les Français donc ça c'est très
clair et je pense que c'est un bon point
de départ et de principe c'est on
s'applique d'abord à nous-mêmes ce qu'on
souhaite ensuite que d'autres puissent
s'appliquer et ensuite je crois que il
parce que en vérité ce que nous disent
aujourd'hui nos concitoyens c'est
concrètement un qu'est-ce que je peux
faire et quel est l'impact que ça parce
que c'est très difficile de mesurer
l'impact des mesures que on peut prendre
quand on dit le chauffage à 19 degrés au
ce genre de choses et bien en effet
réduire de 10% tous notre usage en fait
de l'énergie c'est assurer notre
capacité aussi à pouvoir dans de bonnes
conditions à avoir accès à cette énergie
tout au long des mois qui seront les
plus difficiles on va dire les mois
d'hiver et puis c'est aussi un enjeu sur
la question des prix et la baisse des
prix c'est-à-dire baisser la
consommation évidemment c'est un effet
direct sur la baisse des prix on le voit
bien l'inquiétude majeure aujourd'hui
nos entreprises nos collectivités
locales c'est comment faire face à la
hausse de la facture donc c'est les deux
effets c'est à la fois un enjeu
écologique un enjeu de sobriété mais
c'est aussi une incitation très
puissante parce que ça permet de baisser
les prix et elle inscrit les abattements
cette sobriété dans le temps long est-ce
que ça veut dire que dans les mois à
venir si on voit que les objectifs ne
sont pas suffisamment temps il pourrait
y avoir des obligations notamment pour
les entreprises et pour les
administrations alors les entreprises
elles ont peut-être dans les ménages
alors elles sont pris aujourd'hui des
engagements volontaires mais en vérité
si leur intérêt de les tenir c'est leur
intérêt vis-à-vis des Français parce que
les Français attendent des entreprises
qu'elles soient vertueuses et qu'elles
s'engagent je crois que celles qui ne le
feraient pas se mettre un peu sur le
banc de touche par rapport à celle qui
s'engagent très concrètement c'est leur
intérêt aussi là encore d'un point de
vue économique parce que la facture
énergétique de toute façon nos
entreprises a tellement augmenté dans
des proportions qui sont des
raisonnables et ça c'est tout
l'engagement qu'on a aussi au niveau
européen parce qu'on voit bien
aujourd'hui que les prix ne reflètent
pas la réalité et c'est bien l'enjeu
qu'on a de se dire qu'on doit avoir des
stabilisateurs pour que les prix enfin
reviennent à un niveau normal je crois
qu'aujourd'hui honnêtement tout le monde
veut s'engager tout le monde a intérêt à
s'engager si on devait aller plus loin
ça se regarde évidemment on a pris un
certain nombre de mesures réglementaires
la question des publicités lumineuses
par exemple ça c'est une disposition
réglementaire qui fait qu'à un moment
l'État prend ses responsabilités pour
faire respecter finalement des mesures
de bon sens il y aura pas de retour en
arrière on s'inscrit dans des
restrictions pendant son des incitations
mais qui sont quand même des
restrictions dans le temps long je crois
qu'on est pas vraiment sur des
restrictions on est quand même sur
encore une fois sur des mesures de bon
sens qui sont attendus par les Français
qui sont pertinentes et nécessaires sur
les enjeux écologiques énergétiques et
qui ont aussi un impact économique
important sur le budget puisque ce sera
le texte en examiner dans les prochains
jours à l'Assemblée à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale souhaite que ce
budget tienne compte des débats dans
l'hémicycle et que ce ne soit pas juste
la copie du gouvernement c'est ce que
vous souhaitez aussi c'est ce qu'on
souhaite et c'est ce qui sera fait on
entend beaucoup parler je vais anticiper
sur la prochaine question sur le 49-3 la
manière avec laquelle le budget pourrait
être adopté même s'il y a usage du 49-3
vous le savez à la fois ça arrête le
cours des débats au moment où c'est
utilisé mais ça n'empêche pas de dire
que ça n'est pas la copie initiale qui
va être adoptée ça veut tout à fait dire
que on peut décider d'utiliser le 49-3
parce que on voit bien que les débats ne
permettront pas en fait d'avoir un vote
qui sera un vote positif de l'ensemble
de l'Assemblée nationale et qui
permettrait l'adoption du budget mais
dire aussi c'est pas la copie initiale
qu'on veut c'est
retourner et qui du coup ont des impacts
évidents concrets sur la vie des
français donc ça oui évidemment on va
renforcer notre soutien aux
collectivités locales comme on va
renforcer parce que vous entendez les
élus ils demandent l'indexation de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement sur
l'inflation il faut aller jusque là je
crois pas et je pense pas d'ailleurs
qu'il faille traiter de la même manière
toutes les collectivités locales toutes
n'ont pas le Gédé le même niveau de vie
toutes n'ont pas les mêmes capacités à
faire face que vous soyez une commune
que vous soyez un EPCI que vous soyez un
département ou une région vous n'avez
pas les mêmes moyens pour faire face
pour vous il faut cibler sur les
communes et les petites communes je
pense qu'il faut en effet cibler d'abord
sur ce qu'on appelle le bloc communal
parce que c'est elle qui sont en direct
avec nos concitoyens c'est elle qui
peuvent être encore une fois les plus
vulnérables par rapport à l'envolée des
prix de l'énergie qui sont pas forcément
la capacité à négocier leur contrats
donc oui il y a cette attention là qui
est très forte et nous on va venir
renforcer ses moyens là pareil renforcer
le soutien à nos entreprises aujourd'hui
TPE ou PME par exemple à nos artisans
disent là on a juste un risque très
clair c'est de fermer de pas être en
capacité encore une fois de faire face
parce que certains d'entre eux voient
malheureusement parfois une consommation
qui baisse moins de contrat du fait de
l'inflation et dans le même temps des
prix de l'énergie qui augmentent donc à
un moment ils vont devoir choisir et
équilibrer et le risque c'est qu'à un
moment il ne puisse plus faire face donc
c'est un risque très important pour
l'emploi encore une fois toutes les
mesures qu'on prend quand on parle de
sobriété énergétique c'est pas un coup
de com c'est un enjeu majeur pour faire
face aux risques économiques qui est
derrière et qui est notamment un risque
sur l'emploi pour pour les Français donc
ça c'est des mesures très puissantes
qu'on a votées on veut aussi réorienter
les investissements des Français par
exemple on a fait adopter là la
déduction des intérêts d'emprunt qui
peuvent être réalisés par par les
Français quand il s'agit d'une
acquisition ou de travaux qui vont vers
de l'immobilier vers qui vont vers des
travaux énergétiques et ça je crois que
merdire au maximum en fait la manière
avec laquelle on dépense l'argent public
je crois que c'est une bonne chose
puisque vous me parlez tout à l'heure du
49-3 pour vous il venait inévitable
maintenant sur ce texte disons que les
oppositions nous invitent à l'utiliser
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où
elles ont dit avant même l'examen du
budget avant même de connaître
finalement les termes du débat que quoi
qu'il arrive elle ne le voterait pas on
sait très bien que la seule manière de
pouvoir faire adopter le budget c'est en
effet d'utiliser cet outil qui est prévu
par notre Constitution et je crois que
les Français l'ont compris et je ne vois
pas en fait la difficulté que ça
poserait l'enjeu c'est quoi c'est qui un
débat ça c'est certain c'est pas écraser
le débat en disant que dès le premier
jour et bien immédiatement on l'arrête
c'est évidemment que le débat existe
mais c'est aussi qu'il existe dans des
bonnes conditions pour être intelligible
et surtout qu'ils permettent à un moment
des avancées dans les deux sens on l'a
fait cet été cet été on a réussi à avoir
vraiment du compromis y compris sur un
texte qui était un texte budgétaire
c'est à dire qu'on a fait chacun un pas
l'un vers pour permettre son adoption
aujourd'hui on nous dit on veut bien
discuter mais enfin c'est que sur la
base du projet initial que nous on porte
nous ici LR nous parti socialistes
à faire dans la majorité au gouvernement
on l'a fait cet été par exemple sur la
question du prix des carburants
notamment avec les républicains on l'a
fait sur la question des collectivités
locales avec le Parti socialiste ça veut
dire qu'on a de part et d'autre rejuent
notre copine initiale en se disant à un
moment le compromis ça veut dire
accepter aussi le renoncer parfois à ce
qu'on avait envisagé initialement donc
moi j'attends de voir les propositions
concrètes qui sont faites je suis aussi
très attentive sur la question de la
dépense publique parce que souvent les
mêmes qui disent il faut réduire la
dépense publique quand on est en examen
budgétaire nous propose plutôt en
général des dépenses nouvelles c'est
rare qu'on nous propose de réduire un
certain nombre de dépenses donc on verra
dans le cadre du débat ce qui sera
proposé je le redis même si on devait
utiliser 49-3 ça n'empêche absolument
pas de modifier la copie initiale et
d'accepter des propositions des
oppositions
sur l'amendement que vous souhaitiez
déposer sur le plafonnement des droits
de succession alors ça a pas souhaité ça
a pas franchement engendré un très grand
enthousiasme dans votre majorité vous
allez maintenir cet amendement il n'y a
pas de d'ambiguïté sur le sujet ce qu'on
a proposé pendant la campagne
présidentielle c'est de dire qu'il faut
faciliter évidemment les donations
facilité les successions en termes
d'exonération notamment pour les classes
moyennes c'est ça qui a été dit qui a
été affirmé et ça c'est l'engagement de
notre majorité et l'engagement du
gouvernement on sait qu'on n'a pas les
moyens budgétaires tout simplement de le
voter pour les raisons qu'on a évoquées
notamment sur les questions énergétiques
dès cette année donc ce que j'ai dit en
tant que présidente de groupe c'est on
interpelle le gouvernement sur cette
question pour réaffirmer l'engagement
qui est le nôtre et qu'il n'y ait aucune
ambiguïté vis-à-vis des Français sur le
fait que oui c'est un engagement de
campagne et c'est un engagement de
campagne qui sera tenu dans ce
quinquennat et je vous assure que ça
veut dire qu'il sera pas déposé là ce
sera pour plus tard mais c'était
important des Français de dire
clairement que les engagements pris
pendant la campagne on y renoncé pas
même si on le sait on a une situation
économique qui est en effet tendue
vis-à-vis de notre dépense publique donc
les parlementaires les républicains ils
veulent un amendement similaire ils vont
déposer un amendement similaire ou votre
est-ce que ça veut dire que là vous le
voterez non parce que justement il
demande une réalisation immédiate et eux
ils demandent pas à la baisse de la
dépense publique donc il ne savent pas
le financer aujourd'hui donc moi je
redis très clairement aux Français qui
ont voté pour nous ou même s'ils n'ont
pas voté pour nous qui attendent que
cette mesure entre en rigueur oui ce
sera fait dans ce mandat et c'est pour
ça qu'on a souhaité déposer cet
amendement pour interpeller et pour
réaffirmer l'engagement qui est le nôtre
et par ailleurs on est déjà responsable
et quand on est dans un moment de
tension sur nos finances publiques et
bien on propose
bon parmi les mesures qui sont les
réformes d'ailleurs qui sont présentées
pour faire des économies évidemment la
réforme des retraites il y a une
consultation qui a démarré mercredi
autour de l'évier du soft avec les
syndicats le patronat quelle est
l'utilité de cette tant les positions
sembler sur ce sujet alors est-ce que la
réforme des retraites doit être faite
pour nous la réponse elle est très
claire et c'est oui et encore une fois
le président de la République pendant la
campagne c'est pas caché sur ce sujet là
ça a été très clair là-dessus de débat
de la campagne ils sont très clairs sur
le fait qu'ils ne veulent pas d'un
report de l'âge de départ donc déjà fait
beaucoup de choses qui devaient discuter
dans le cadre de cette réforme il y a
non seulement la question du travailler
plus c'est-à-dire le report de l'âge
légal notamment ou la question de la
durée des cotisations mais il y a aussi
dans quelles conditions on travaille
c'est la question de l'emploi des
seniors notamment c'est la question de
la pénibilité c'est la question de la
prise en compte des carrières longues
des carrières aussi coupées notamment
des femmes et la question enfant du
minimum de retraite que l'on doit à ceux
qui ont travaillé tout au long de leur
vie donc c'est là dessus qu'on doit
pouvoir discuter avec les syndicats
est-ce qu'on arrivera à avoir un accord
unanime sur l'hypothèse même et
l'opportunité d'une réforme je ne crois
pas par contre est-ce que c'est sans
discuter avec les partenaires sociaux je
pense que la réponse est oui et est-ce
qu'ils peuvent vous apporter des
propositions notamment encore une fois
je pense à l'emploi des seniors je pense
que ça c'est essentiel que les
partenaires sociaux que les syndicats
s'engagent dans ses doigts mais il y
aura aucun compromis puisque c'est ce
qui pose problème c'est pas tant
l'emploi des seniors c'est le recul de
l'âge de départ il y aura aucun
compromis de la part de la majorité du
gouvernement sur le report de l'âge de
départ et sur l'augmentation de la durée
de cotisation mais s'il n'y a pas le
travail plus il y a pas la capacité à
financer aujourd'hui celles et ceux qui
sont à la retraite le point de départ
c'est quand même ça c'est pas de dire on
doit faire des économies c'est de dire
pour assurer ne serait-ce que le modèle
social dans lequel nous vivons
aujourd'hui pour assurer de financer les
retraites de ceux qui sont déjà en
retraite aujourd'hui parce qu'il faut
quand même que nos retraités l'entende
et eux le savent ils savent que si cette
réforme n'est pas engagée cette réforme
n'est pas réalisée ce qui promet de
partir toujours plus tôt ne savent pas
derrière financer ceux qui sont déjà à
la retraite ne savent pas financer
demain le minimum de retraite pour ceux
qui ont travaillé tout au long de leur
vie ne savent pas non plus prendre en
compte les questions essentiel de
carrière longue ou de carrière hachée
notamment pour les femmes donc c'est
pour ça qu'on doit le faire c'est pas
générer d'abord des économies c'est
s'assurer de la viabilité sur le moyen
et le long terme d'un système je pense
tout le monde se félicite personne
d'ailleurs n'a demandé à changer le
système personne ne dit aujourd'hui
qu'on doit plus être dans un système par
répartition on aurait pu avoir une
nouvelle voix c'est pas du tout celle
qu'on emprunte mais il faut de la
responsabilités oui enfin derrière vous
vous souvenez pendant la campagne
présidentielle qu'on leur posait la
question à retraite à 60 ans mais avec
combien en durée de cotisations là
c'était tout de suite déjà beaucoup plus
ambigu et puis est-ce que vous êtes
capable dans ces cas-là de maintenir le
niveau des pensions actuelles là aussi
c'était plus ambigu parce que la réponse
elle est claire c'est que si c'est la
retraite à 60 ans et bien on ne peut pas
financer aujourd'hui nos pensions de
retraite sauf augmenter les impôts des
Français est-ce que cette fois vous irez
au bout quoi qu'il arrive vous
repousserez l'âge légal de départ quoi
qu'il arrive même si les syndicats sont
contre et même s'ils éventuellement la
Russe mobilise mais la réponse c'est oui
la réponse c'est oui on a reçu un mandat
clair des Français sur ce sujet là
encore une fois on aurait pu faire en
sorte de minimiser la question de dire
écouter on verra après la campagne
présidentielle et les législatives on
ouvrira des négociations tout sera sur
la table etc Emmanuel Macron dans
l'entre-deux tours les 65 ans il est un
peu revenu dessus il a dit les 65 ans
c'est plus un tabou on verra ça sera
peut-être 64 en 2028 on verra sur 65
Marine Le Pen cette question de la
réforme des retraites et cette question
on l'a assumé nous-mêmes dans nos
propres campagnes législatives peut-être
que ça nous a coûté j'en ai honnête
parce que c'était une mesure qui était
difficile qui n'est jamais la mesure la
plus populaire mais c'est à la fois le
marqueur je crois du courage et de la
nécessité de la volonté de la réforme
mais c'est surtout une nécessité sur le
fond pour qu'on doit le faire on s'est
beaucoup pas tardé je comprends pourquoi
sur la question de la méthode quand
est-ce que cette réforme devait
intervenir je crois que ce qui intéresse
les Français c'est surtout qu'est-ce que
vous mettez dans cette réforme quand
est-ce que moi je suis pas loin de la
retraite je pourrais solder mes droits à
la retraite par exemple qu'est-ce que je
vais toucher moi comme retraite demain
alors que aujourd'hui on me dit que
j'aurai une toute petite pension de
retraite est-ce que moi en tant que
femme qui est dû m'arrêter de travailler
parfois et je serais mieux prise en
compte demain c'est tout ça qu'on doit
faire avec les Français vous entendez la
France insoumise dire que s'il le faut
il déposeront des milliers d'amendements
va-t-il panneau parle même de 75000
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ils ont
déjà fait ça par le passé je suis pas
sûr que l'obstruction soit un bon signe
de vie démocratique et quand je vois les
propos de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui dans
une espèce de métaphore par rapport à ce
qui s'était passé lors de la Révolution
française considère qu'il faudrait faire
mieux faire mieux que d'arriver à
emmener le roi et la reine c'est quoi
c'est soit la guillotine pour le
président de la République donc on va le
voir ce tweet juste un pour que ça soit
clair pour tout le monde parce
qu'effectivement Jean-Luc Mélenchon il
appelle à une marche contre la vie
Charles 16 octobre et hier il a fait un
tweet en disant le 5 et 6 octobre 1789
les femmes marcheraient ça et contre la
vie chère elle ramène le roi et la reine
et le dauphin de force à Paris sous
contrôle populaire faites mieux le 16
octobre c'est un appel à la sédition
en tout cas le fait mieux je j'aimerais
qu'il clarifie sa position faites mieux
que l'usage de la force pour les ramener
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire concrètement
et je crois pas que soit niveau
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de ses
partenaires politiques l'ont appelé
alors sur le sujet mais je pense que
malheureusement depuis des semaines si
ce n'est des mois et discréditer je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il n'arrive pas
au sein de la France insoumise
d'ailleurs à rompre définitivement avec
ces méthodes et avec lui je crois qu'il
n'est pas crédible pour continuer à être
un homme politique parce qu'il n'est pas
responsable et dit dans ses propos et
que appeler à la haine appelée à la
violence on l'a subi dans le précédent
mandat les élus l'ont subi dans le
précédent mandat et je crois pas que la
société souhaite que la violence en
permanence s'installe qu'elle s'installe
dans nos débats parlementaires qu'elle
s'installe dans nos débats même
télévisés qu'elle s'installe en général
partout dans la société et
l'irresponsable politique ne devrait
jamais jamais plaider pour la violence
ça veut dire qu'il est plus à la hauteur
aujourd'hui pour vous Jean-Luc pour moi
de manière très claire et très nette je
crois qu'à quand on se dit républicain
et démocrate il y a des mots des
méthodes des attitudes qu'on n'a pas le
droit d'employer parce qu'on a valeurs
républicain pour vous ce truc là on a
valeur d'exemple quand on a été candidat
à plusieurs fois l'élection
présidentielle quand des millions de
Français à un moment ont cru au projet
politique que vous portiez forcément
vous avez une voix qui porte et qui est
entendue et bien moi je considère qu'en
effet à partir du moment où vous appelez
à la force et à la violence vous êtes
discrédité et vous n'êtes pas digne de
représenter les Français puisqu'on parle
de la France insoumise vous avez posé
une question d'actualité mercredi donc
gouvernement pardon qui a un peu
enflammé l'hémicycle et notamment la
France insoumise et la nuque puisque
vous faisiez allusion sans vraiment le
citer à Adrien catenens qui a reconnu
avoir donné une gifle à son épouse vous
qui prenez le dialogue le compromis avec
les oppositions est-ce que vous
regrettez cette question est-ce que vous
êtes allé un peu trop loin ce que je
regrette c'est ceux qui ont continué à
défendre un homme qui a reconnu des
faits constructifs de violences
conjugales ce que je regrette c'est là
encore l'attitude de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et d'autres qui disent qu'ils je cite de
l'affection pour quelqu'un qui frappe sa
femme moi j'ai très peu d'affection pour
quelqu'un qui frappe sa femme alors vous
avez entendu les députés de la France
insoumise qui après cette mission vous
ont répondu Aurore berger elle pose une
question quand c'est Adrien catenens
mais on l'a pas entendu quand c'était
Damien bad qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça mais je réponds tout simplement qu'il
y a un principe qui est l'État de droit
et que dans un cas vous avez un homme
qui a reconnu des faits qui sont
constitutifs de violences conjugales
mais il n'a pas été jugé mais il les a
reconnu mais il n'a pas été jugés
qui est selon moi n'a pas sa place dès
lors dans l'hémicycle c'est la
responsabilité qu'il prendra ou qu'il ne
prendra pas à sa place dans le métier
que ça veut dire qu'il doit quitter son
poste de député pour écouter aujourd'hui
la réponse de la France insoumise et de
dire qu'il a besoin de se mettre un peu
en retrait pour préparer un divorce qui
est difficile la question n'est pas de
préparer son divorce auprès du
contribuable la question est qu'à partir
du moment où il a reconnu des faits de
violence conjugales est-ce qu'il est
digne pour représenter les femmes et les
Français et puis dans d'autres cas vous
avez en effet des hommes qui ont pu être
mais qui nie tous les faits qui leur
sont reprochés et pour lesquels il y a
une information judiciaire qui est
ouverte moi je ne peux pas dire avant la
justice ce qui a existé ou pas je ne
suis pas là pour établir une vérité
judiciaire et c'est ça la différence et
la différence aussi c'est que moi
contrairement à la France insoumise j'ai
jamais eu comme ligne de conduite de
penser qu'accusation va les culpabilité
j'ai jamais pensé non plus qu'en
fonction des hommes ou des femmes qui
étaient mis en cause il fallait changer
de discours c'était des gens qui étaient
dans notre parti politique ou qui ne
l'était pas et je crois qu'ils sont mis
aujourd'hui face à leurs ambiguïtés et
face à leur ambivalence permanence sur
ce sujet là parce que dès qu'ils sont
directement concernés en vérité ils ne
sache plus
finalement assumer la propre ligne
qu'ils ont pourtant en permanence voulue
portez vis-à-vis des autres et encore
une fois j'ai du mal à comprendre
comment on peut maintenir garder et
proclamer son affection pour un homme
qui frappe sa femme alors que pour vous
il faut qu'il démissionne de son mandat
et ce sera sa responsabilité à minima
son groupe aurait pu considérer qu'il
pouvait être exclu de ce groupe
politique je crois que ça aurait été un
signal extrêmement clair et net à partir
du moment encore une fois où il a
reconnu les faits il y aurait uniquement
une information judiciaire il n'irait
les faits on serait dans une situation
qui serait différente et je crois que
juste pour Julien Bayou lui il nie les
faits qui lui sont reprochés il est
accusé de violence psychologique et
pourtant il a dû démissionner de ses
fonctions de secrétaire de repécologie
les verts et de la présidence du groupe
écologie c'est allé trop loin ça pour
vous oui et de la même manière on a un
autre dysfonctionnement il y a un
dysfonctionnement de la France insoumise
dans l'affaire Adrien katns et un
dysfonctionnement majeur au sein du
parti europécologique concernant Julien
Bayou c'est à dire que là on a un homme
politique qui est accusé de fait qu'il
ne connaît pas dont il n'a pas le droit
de se défendre sur lesquels il n'a pas
été entendu et Tonton dit même s'il
était de toute façon ils ne sont pas
pénalement répréhensibles donc on a
l'impression d'avoir une exécution
politique interne qui fait appel à
l'arbitraire c'est ce que tout d'un coup
sur un plateau de une vision on vient
dévoiler l'intimité d'une relation où
l'intimité supposée d'une relation sans
que la personne mise en cause et la
moindre capacité à répondre et à se
défendre et c'est la limite aussi de ces
partis politiques qui ont voulu non pas
créer des cellules qui sont là pour
prévenir des risques de violence
sexuelle et sexistes ou accompagner les
femmes mais qui ont voulu en interne
rendre la justice on ne rend pas la
justice en interne la cellule qui a été
créée à Renaissance qui sera présidé par
Malène Schiappa elle ne prendra aucune
décision de retrait ou de démission de
personnes elle sera là uniquement pour
écouter et ensuite elle transmettra la
justice pour accompagner les victimes
potentielles vers la seule voie qui peut
encore une fois mettre un terme aux
souffrances qu'elles peuvent avoir c'est
à dire la voie judiciaire et
malheureusement
d'une éventuelle mise en retrait ou
d'une démission d'une personne
elle ira jamais sur un plateau de
télévision dévoiler l'intimité de tel ou
telle couple de tel ou tel personnalité
politique pour pour l'exécuter
politiquement par contre elle elle est
particulièrement attachée à la
protection des femmes à la protection
des victimes quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs homme ou femme et nos
cellules elles doivent d'abord permettre
ça comme dans les entreprises ce sont
d'abord des cellules qui doivent écouter
qui doivent prévenir mais qui ne peuvent
en aucun cas se substituer à la justice
merci au revoir merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invitation président du groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale on
face au club des territoires
[Musique]